der diesel skandal führt jetzt auch die
konsequenzen für unsere gesundheit gift
in deutschen städten neue zahlen zeigen
dass langsam äußerst kritisch
mitbekommen zu klicks um seiten fiction
in china ist das problem der
verschmutzten luft an der tagesordnung
in 90 prozent der 190 großstädte in
china werden regelmäßig die von der
chinesischen regierung selbst gesetzten
grenzwerte für feinstaub in der luft
überschritten
greenpeace warnt davor nicht gegen die
gesundheitsgefahren durch feinstaub
belastung aktiv zu werden
die von der regierung angekündigten
schutzmaßnahmen müssten schnellstmöglich
umgesetzt werden
in deutschland scheint es als bräuchten
wir bis auf umweltplaketten rot gelb
grün keine schutzmaßnahmen den bericht
das umweltbundesamt zufolge sollten sich
das aber vor allem bezogen auf den
stickstoffdioxid gehalt der luft
schleunigst ändern
die teilweise viel diskutierte blaue
plakette für sehr umweltfreundliche
fahrzeuge könnte dabei helfen die dort
seit jahrzehnten gefördert
stickstoffdioxid und gesundheit schuld
wird in den städten vor allem alte
dieselautos es kann auch sich das
gesundheits produkt nicht akzeptiert
werden dass die kommunen keine handhabe
haben um beispielsweise dieselautos mit
hohem ausstoß auf den belasteten
innenstädten auszuschließen deutschland
ist auch gegenüber der eu verpflichtet
für saubere luft in den städten zu
sorgen
dazu kann die blaue plakette einen
wichtigen beitrag leisten
die kommunen brauchen eine
bundeseinheitliche regelung die festlegt
wer die blaue plakette bekommt und wer
nichts schief geht es darum die
gesundheit ihrer bürgerinnen und bürger
zu schützen so die worte der präsidentin
des umweltbundesamts maria krautzberger
um unsere gesundheit steht das kurz
gesagt wirklich nicht gut auf der
homepage von umweltbundesamt heißt es
von stickstoffdioxid gehalt der luft an
gut 57 prozent der verkehrsnahen
messstationen wurde der grenzwert von 40
mikrogramm pro kubikmeter im
jahresmittel überschritten in einer
endlos erscheint in excel tabelle werden
unzählige städte mit ihren messwerten
aufgelistet wer sich dafür interessiert
wird um seine stadt steht findet den
link dazu natürlich in der video
beschreibt
passend zum thema kann ich euch das
video over schub day der tag an dem die
erde verbraucht empfehlen wenn euch das
interessiert dann schaut mal einfach
hier vorbei wenn ich auf diese gefallen
hat dann macht mir auch gerne einen
daumen nach oben und ein kostenloses abo
dafür viel klicken und lassen wir eure
meinungen erfahrungen für luft in
deutschen städten
also wie gebt euch damit hat
irgendwelche veränderungen festgestellt
und bis dahin bis morgen